herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
heute vor genau drei Wochen da begann er
der russische Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine heute vor genau drei Wochen
wachte Europa auf und erkannte die Welt
ist eine andere Europa befindet sich im
Krieg obwohl der russische Präsident
Putin in seiner Rede am frühen Morgen
des 24 februar in seiner Kriegserklärung
deutlich gemacht hat dass er die
ukrainische Regierung in Kiew wegfegen
beseitigen will ist der ukrainische
Präsident selensky weiterhin in Kiew als
die USA vlodimier selensky anboten ihn
auszufliegen ihn rauszuholen aus Kiew in
Sicherheit zu bringen der antwortete
selensky Mein Kampf ist hier ich brauche
Munition keine Mitfahrgelegenheit jeden
Tag spricht der per Videobotschaft über
Social Media zu seinen Landsleuten macht
ihnen Mut aber er spricht auch über
Social Media über seine Videobotschaften
an im Westen seiner Appelle seine
Botschaften gehen an den Westen gibt und
Waffen helft uns uns zu verteidigen
heute nun spricht selensky zum Deutschen
Bundestag wir werden um 9 Uhr live
dorthin schalten das live-signal liegt
bereits vor ein Dolmetscher ist auch
dabei das heißt wir können die Rede von
selenski live verfolgen und verstehen
und natürlich wollen wir die Rede dann
auch anschließend besprechen besprechen
und analysieren zunächst aber wollen wir
mit unserer hauptstadtkorrespondentin
schakuntala benerji sprechen tagundella
schönen guten Morgen guten Morgen
wie ist diese Rede vor den deutschen
Abgeordneten vor dem deutschen Parlament
heute einzuordnen welche Bedeutung hat
sie
ja das ist schon ein historischer Moment
das sagte zum Beispiel heute morgen im
Deutschlandfunk auch Alexander Graf
Lambsdorff Bundestagsmitglied der FDP er
sagte das habe es so in dieser Form noch
nicht gegeben es ist immer etwas
Besonderes wenn ein Staatschef vor dem
Bundestag spricht aber diese Situation
dass sich jemand aus dem Kriegsgebiet
meldet aus einer unter Beschuss
stehenden Hauptstadt die hat es so
tatsächlich noch nicht gegeben
entsprechend emotional aufgeladen ist
diese ganze Veranstaltung auch es gab im
Vorfeld Debatten darüber ob der
Bundestag richtig damit umgeht denn wir
werden gleich die Rede von selensky
hören und direkt im Anschluss daran geht
es praktisch mit dem normalen
Tagesprogramm weiter ich habe mir das
hier noch mal hingelegt da kommt dann
direkt im Anschluss die Debatte zur
Impfpflicht danach geht es um sichere
Energieversorgung dann gibt es noch eine
Menge anderer Punkte und erst um 15 Uhr
folgt dann noch einmal eine Aussprache
die die Union beantragt hatte zum Thema
Ukrain aber auch nur indirekt zur
Situation dort nämlich es geht eher um
die Versorgung und Registrierung und
Verteilung von Flüchtlingen und darüber
gab es im Vorfeld Streit weil die Union
aus der Oppositionsrolle herausgesagt
hat das kann man so nicht machen so
sollte man mit dem Präsidenten nicht
umgehen wir sollten direkt im Anschluss
darüber reden aus der Bundesregierung
gab es gab es Widerspruch da haben wir
gehört dass
es doch gerade ein besonderer Moment sei
wenn man das Wort von Woody music
einfach mal so stehen lässt und dann
nicht im Anschluss daran direkt
kommentiert das hat Annalena baerbock
gesagt
darüber müssen wir gleich noch
weiterreden tagunterlage wie das Ganze
einzuschätzen ist zunächst aber wollen
wir einfach mal schauen du hast es schon
gesagt das ist etwas ganz Besonderes das
ein Staatsoberhaupt oder ein
Regierungschef zum Deutschen Bundestag
spricht und dann eben auch noch ja im
Grunde genommen aus dem Bunker raus weil
gerade Krieg ist wir wollen deshalb
erstmal einen kurzen Überblick bekommen
wie den ganz aktuell wie heute die Lage
im Kriegsgebiet in der Ukraine ist
schwere Explosionen zerstören ein
Theater in mariopol laut örtlichen
Behörden sollen sich mehr als 1.000
Schutz Suchende in dem Gebäude
aufgehalten haben als es offenbar von
russischen Luftangriffen getroffen wird
Russland streitet dies ab zuvor war
gestern mehreren tausend Menschen die
Flucht aus der umkämpften Hafenstadt
gelungen auch im nördlichen harkev gehen
die Angriffe weiter ein Markt soll hier
Ziel eines Angriffs geworden sein der
laut ukrainischem Notfalldienst ein
riesiges Feuer auslöste auf den
russischen Angriff auf die Ukraine durch
Präsident Putin findet der US-Präsident
deutlich Worte ich denke er ist ein
Kriegsverbrecher Verhandlungen zwischen
den Kriegsparteien scheinen Fortschritte
zu machen Präsident selensky betont aber
weiterhin seine Forderungen meine
Prioritäten bei den Gesprächen sind ganz
klar Beendigung des Krieges
Sicherheitsgarantien Souveränität
Wiederherstellung der territorialen
Integrität echte Garantien für unser
Land echter Schutz unseres Landes
solange es keine Einigung gibt bereiten
sich ukrainische Soldaten auf weitere
Kämpfe vor man wolle weiterhin in einer
Demokratie leben sagt einer von ihnen
tja während also Präsident selenski der
ukrainische Regierungschefs hier
sprechen wird vor dem Deutschen
Bundestag per Videoschalte fliegen
Raketen in Kiew wird weiter gekämpft
reden wir mit Katrin Eigendorf unserer
Korrespondentin unsere Reporterin die in
Odessa jetzt ist da Rücken auch die
russischen Truppen vor Katrin wie ist
denn jetzt eigentlich die Lage
ja es hat heute morgen hier auch wieder
drei Einschläge gegeben also der Krieg
rückt auch hier in Odessa näher die
Stadt ist natürlich strategisch für
Russland ziemlich wichtig es ist die
größte Hafenstadt der Ukraine es ist die
drittgrößte Stadt und auch wenn man sich
auf der Karte anguckt es wäre natürlich
ein territorial großer Gewinn auch
Odessa noch zu besetzen und damit
rechnet man hier in der Stadt darauf
richten sich die Menschen hier ein schon
seit Tagen die ganze Stadt ist voll von
Barrikaden überall hat man hier selbst
gebaute Panzersperren aufgebaut die
Situation ist hier wirklich angespannt
und die Stadt ist natürlich noch mal
besonders exponiert weil man rechnet
damit dass hier auch über den Seeweg
also über die russische Marine Angriffe
erfolgen könnten
wie ist denn jetzt eigentlich aus
ukrainischer Sicht ist zu sehen dass
selensky vor oder zum Deutschen
Bundestag per Video schalte spricht was
verspricht man sich was hält man davon
welche Bedeutung hat das
Deutschland hat für die Ukraine
insgesamt eine sehr große Bedeutung es
ist das wichtigste Land einer der
wichtigsten Partner in Europa man sieht
in Deutschland natürlich auch jemanden
ein Land das einen noch gesprächskanal
eventuell zu Wladimir Putin herstellen
kann sowie auch Frankreich und man sieht
Deutschland natürlich auch in der NATO
als als einen wichtigen möglichen
Fürsprecher allerdings muss man auch
sagen ich denke ich erwarte das Wladimir
selensky mit Deutschland auch ein
bisschen ins Gericht gehen wird denn was
man hier Deutschland vorwirft und das
hat ganz besonders der ukrainische
Außenminister ja wiederholt getan das
über Jahre die dieser Kriecher nun schon
dauert vor allem Deutschland immer
wieder die Situation
verharmlost habe und im Prinzip Wladimir
Putin in einer gewissen Art und Weise
hoffe ich gemacht hat indem man immer
wieder mit ihm Abkommen geschlossen hat
indem man sich zum Beispiel so sehr
abhängig gemacht hat auch von russisch
Spaß das sieht man hier in der Ukraine
sehr kritisch ich denke diese Rede von
silensky wird sicherlich sehr sehr
emotional sein wir haben ihn immer
wieder erlebt der ist ja im Prinzip in
diesem Krieg eigentlich muss man sagen
der Anti Putin ein moderner offener
relativ klar sprechender Mensch der
nicht vom Zettel abliest wie ich gehört
habe hat er diese Rede selbst konzipiert
und verfasst also da waren keine
Redenschreiber am Werk ich bin wirklich
gespannt was er dem deutschen Parlament
zu sagen hat
ja vielen Dank Katrin in Odessa für
diese Einschätzung es sind ungefähr noch
zwei Minuten wir sehen dass Parlament
füllt sich so langsam und wir werden auf
jeden Fall live nach Berlin gehen wenn
Vladimir selenski sprechen wird wir
nutzen die letzten Sekunden einmal noch
mal um mit Shark unterlab energy zu
sprechen wir haben es jetzt von Katrin
Eigendorf gehört es hatte auch viel
Kritik ja gegeben von der Ukraine von
selenski an Deutschland hat sich
Deutschland da auch einiges verschärft
wir erinnern uns mal daran da war die
Ukraine schon umzingelt von russischen
Truppen Deutschland hat 5000 Helme
geliefert ja natürlich waren die
Reaktionen darauf nicht besonders
erfreut das haben wir in den vergangenen
Wochen auch gehört allerdings hat man
auch gesehen dass sich die ukrainische
Regierung auf eine Kommunikation verlegt
hat die darauf
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja auf
harte Kritik und wenn man sich mal
anschaut wie wo Lotti mir selensky in
seinen Reden zur Öffentlichkeit jetzt
agiert würde ich erwarten dass er auch
heute im Bundestag versucht seine
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer emotional zu
erreichen und auch Anknüpfungspunkte zu
finden das war ja sehr interessant
gestern im US-Kongress das er Pearl
Harbor den Angriff auf Pearl Harbor
durch die Japaner im Zweiten Weltkrieg
zitiert hat und dass er auch gesagt hat
bei uns gibt es jetzt jeden Tag ein Nein
eleven also auch eine Ereignis zitiert
hat die Terroranschläge vom 11 September
in den USA das den Amerikanern sehr nahe
geht und dadurch eben eine direkte
Verbindung geschaffen hat um den
Menschen zu vermitteln wie es sich
anfühlt in der Ukraine wie groß die
Angst ist das sehen wir natürlich jeden
Tag auf den Bildern aber er fügt dem
ganzen eben eine persönliche
persönliche Note noch hinzu und einen
persönlichen Aspekt und
dann wahrscheinlich darauf dass er
dadurch auch mehr Hilfe bekommt in den
USA hat das anscheinend auch
funktioniert er hat gestern noch mal die
Zusage bekommen von 800 Milliarden
US-Dollar zusätzlicher
Militärhilfe was er heute genau fordern
wird ist nicht klar aber wir kennen ja
seine Kernforderungen das ist zum einen
mehr Geld aber vor allem mehr Waffen und
die Einrichtung einer Flugverbotszone
die am besten durch die NATO gesichert
werden sollte das ist ein großer Wunsch
damit wird der hier allerdings
wahrscheinlich nicht auf offene Ohren
treffen die Haltung der Bundesregierung
ist ganz klar gewesen und wird sie
wahrscheinlich auch weiterhin bleiben
die NATO darf sich dort nicht
involvieren und die Einrichtung einer
Flugverbotszone wäre eine solche
Involvierung und man sieht das Risiko
dass man dann eben in direkte
Konfrontation mit den Russen kommt und
möglicherweise am Anfang eines Dritten
Weltkrieges Stunde
du hast es zusammengefasst es ist eine
spannende Rede die wir jetzt erwarten
oder mit Spannung wird diese Rede
erwartet weil halt viel zündstoffe auch
drin steckt wir haben eben wir sehen
immer wieder die Bilder eben auch aus
dem Bundestag noch ist selenski nicht
zugeschaltet noch reden die Abgeordneten
miteinander und auf der Tribüne habe ich
eben oder haben wir eben auch den
ukrainischen Botschafter in Deutschland
gesehen er wird also die Rede seines
Präsidenten sozusagen mitverfolgen dann
eben über den videochirmen im Bundestag
und der hat ja auch kräftig Kritik
geäußert war also entsetzt darüber dass
Deutschland ja im Grunde genommen auf
die Bremse tritt wenn es um Sanktionen
geht oder in der Vergangenheit ging wir
erinnern uns wenn es darum ging die
Russen auszuschließen aus dem
internationalen Zahlungsverkehr Swift
Deutschland hat da auf die Bremse
getreten
russisches Gas und Erdöl sozusagen zu
boykottieren nicht mehr zu importieren
auch da tritt Deutschland auf die Bremse
und sagt das können wir jetzt noch nicht
während andere wie die USA es ganz
einfach fordern und auch machen also da
sind viele Dinge die große Kritik
ausgelöst hat und erst mit zögern hat
Deutschland ein bisschen eine Kehrtwende
gemacht und eben nicht nur 5000 Helme
geliefert sondern nach langem langem
Zögern eben auch
Panzerabwehrwaffen aus alten NVA
Beständen statt Unterlagen können wir
also viel Kritik von silensky heute auch
erwarten oder ist am Ende die
Möglichkeit dass die
Bundestagsabgeordneten durch Applaus
eben auch Solidarität zeigen am Ende
etwas wo die Deutschen doch auch ein
Signal senden können an die Ukraine
also ich glaube es wird beides passieren
selensky wird schon sehr deutlich sagen
was er erwartet und an welchen Stellen
er sich nicht genug unterstützt fühlt
und an welchen Stellen er die
Unterstützung Deutschlands für die
Ukraine in diesem Krieg auch erwartet
aber dass er Standing Ovations bekommt
davon würde ich jetzt mal fest ausgehen
das haben wir in Europäischen Parlament
gesehen vor dem er gesprochen hat das
haben wir auch im US-Kongress gesehen
das ist ja auch ein äußeres Zeichen der
Solidarität und ist momentan muss man ja
leider an vielen Stellen sagen so dass
nicht das einzige aber doch ein das eine
große Zeichen was man geben kann damit
wird er nicht zufrieden sein am Ende
aber Solidarität ist natürlich am
einfachsten jetzt zu vermitteln deswegen
glaube ich dass selbst wenn er harte
Kritik äußern sollte er doch sehr
deutlichen Applaus und wahrscheinlich
auch Standing Ovations bekommen wird
wir haben gerade du hast das
angesprochen andere Melnik gesehen den
ukrainischen Botschafter der ist ja hier
in Deutschland zuständig die Kritik der
Ukraine wirklich schonungslos
vorzutragen und zwar in einer Art und
Weise die hier in Berlin oft für
Stirnrunzeln sorgt weil man das so von
Diplomaten nicht gewohnt ist und wenn
man sagt normalerweise ist ein
Botschafter eben da zurückhaltender das
ist ja der Kern der Diplomatie immer
freundlich zu bleiben das tut andere
Melnik nicht hat dafür auch Kritik hier
kassiert
es gab einen einen Tweet der gestern
vorgestern entschuldigung da habe ich
jetzt nicht mehr den genauen Tag im Kopf
gemacht
jetzt geht's los dass ich hier auch auf
dem Schirm genau so ist es schon Gunter
la Katrin gehören Eckert Vize
Bundestagspräsidentin spricht jetzt also
werden wir jetzt in schalten anscheinend
hat es erst ein bisschen technische
Probleme gegeben aber wir hören jetzt
rein und hoffen dass wir gemeinsam jetzt
da sehen wir ihn selensky und Applaus
der Bundestagsabgeordneten dann rede
wird jetzt beginnen und wir gehören
gemeinsam zu und werden nachher drüber
sprechen
[Applaus]
es ist uns eine Ehre dass sie heute zu
uns sprechen werden auf der Tribüne
begrüße ich auch und von Herzen
Botschafter André Melnik schön dass sie
erneut bei uns sind
seit Jahren ist Krieg die Krim der
donbas wurden überfallen und der neue
eiskalte brutale Angriff auf die Ukraine
auf die Freiheit auf die Demokratie
schafft ein Leid dessen Ausmaß wir hier
nur erahnen können seit drei Wochen
leisten die Menschen in der Ukraine mit
allen Kräften Widerstand gegen Putins
Angriffskrieg dieser Krieg muss beendet
werden Russland muss seine Angriffe
einstellen und seine Truppen aus der
Ukraine abziehen
die überwältigende Mehrheit der
Staatengemeinschaft hat diese Forderung
an Russland in der Generalversammlung
der Vereinten Nationen bekräftigt den
Angriffskrieg verurteilt mit Entsetzen
sehen wir dass die russischen Truppen
bewusst zivile Ziele angreifen das ist
ein eklatanter Verstoß gegen das
humanitäre Völkerrecht
zivile
zivile Angriffe das klingt technisch
aber das sind Wohnhäuser Krankenhäuser
Schulen Kindergärten es trifft
schutzlose Menschen alte die in Kellern
sitzen und nicht fliehen konnten weil
sie zu krank sind
Schwangere ja Wöchnerinnen mit ihren
Neugeborenen
wir sind tief berührt von den Mädchen
das offenbar in einem Bunker singt ein
Lied aus der Eiskönigin wir sehen dich
Amelia
Menschen sind tot
der ukrainische Biathlet
Mali Schiff ist tot
die Fußballprofis
Vitali
Malenko sind tot
Reporterinnen die über den Krieg
berichtet haben sind tot ihre Namen
kennen wir viele andere so viele andere
kennen wir nicht doch wir sehen euch wir
sind in Gedanken bei Euch und bei denen
die um euch trauern
die Stadt mariopol erlebt eine
Katastrophe
auch in irpin Rake Restaurant an vielen
vielen anderen großen und kleinen Orten
besteht eine dramatische Notlage die
Menschen brauchen Hilfe schnell und ohne
Gefahr vor neuen Angriffen sie müssen
wenigstens die umkämpften Orte auf
sicheren Wegen verlassen können
Millionen Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
sind geflohen tausende suchen jeden Tag
Zuflucht auch in unserem Land viele
Menschen in den Nachbarländern der
Ukraine und auch Deutschland helfen wo
sie können sammeln Spenden organisieren
Hilfsleistungen kümmern sich um die
Kriegsflüchtlinge sie spüren das neben
menschlicher Solidarität eine
entschlossene Politik notwendig ist
Putin hat mit seinem Krieg auch unsere
Friedensordnung angegriffen herr
Präsident lieber weil er mit dir
silensky
wir können Sie sehen ihr Land hat sich
für die Demokratie entschieden und genau
das fürchtet wieder sie mir Putin er
versucht ihrem Land eine eigene
Geschichte
Identität
Existenzrecht abzusprechen doch damit
ist er schon jetzt gescheitert
die Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer sind
geeinter und entschlossener als je zuvor
sie zeigen jeden Tag wie stark ihr
Freiheitswille ist
und ich sage das auch ganz persönlich
herr Präsident als jemand der in der DDR
aufgewachsen ist und Teil der
friedlichen Revolution war weiß ich dass
Freiheit ein Geschenk ist
und doch immer wieder erkämpft werden
muss
2004 durfte ich auf dem Mai dann
sprechen als hunderttausende für
Demokratie in ihrem Land demonstriert
haben ein Satz der demonstrantenen von
damals hat sich mir eingebrannt
zusammen sind wir viele wir sind nicht
zu besiegen
der Weg den Ukraine bestritten hat war
nicht leicht er war konsequent er war
demokratisch europäisch so wie auch ihre
Wahl zum Präsidenten dieses wunderbar
stolzen Landes herr Präsident liebe
wollen sie mir selenski die Welt steht
der Ukraine bei Deutschland steht an
ihrer Seite sie haben das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler Scholz
liebe Damen und Herren Abgeordnete und
Gäste Journalisten die auch anwesend
sind
und liebes Volk Deutschlands ich spreche
sie an nach drei Wochen das
allumfängliches Krieges den Russland
gegen die Ukraine führt nach acht Jahren
Krieg im Osten meines Landes im Don Bass
ich spreche sie an als Russland uns
bombardiert unsere Städte zerstört und
alles zerstört was wir in der Ukraine
aufgebaut haben Wohnhäuser Krankenhäuser
Schulen Kirchen
sind Raketen es sind Bomben es ist
Artillerie schwere Artillerie in diesen
drei Wochen sind
viele Menschen gefallen tausende Ukraine
die Besatzer haben
108 Kinder schon getötet im Mitten
Europas in der Mitte Europas in 2022
ich spreche sie an nach zahlreichen
Treffen zahlreichen Verhandlungen und
vielen Schritten die uns unterstützen
manche Schritte waren allzu spät getan
diese Sanktionen waren anscheinend nicht
genug um den Krieg zu stoppen und
nachdem wir gesehen haben
wie viele Verbindungen ihre
Konzerne noch mit Russland haben mit
einem Land das auch Sie und andere
Länder dazu nutzt um den Krieg zu
finanzieren in diesen drei Wochen des
Krieges wir kämpfen um unser Leben um
unsere Freiheit und wir haben
wir sind jetzt dessen sicher was wir
früher schon gespürt haben und dass die
Welt vielleicht noch nicht so deutlich
gesehen hat und sie sind
durch eine Art Mauer von uns getrennt es
ist keine Berliner Mauer es ist eine
Mauer inmitten Europas zwischen Freiheit
und Unfreiheit und dieses Mauer wird
größer mit jeder Bombe die auf die
Ukraine fällt mit jeder nicht
getroffenen Entscheidung mit einer nicht
getroffenen Entscheidung für den Frieden
die uns helfen könnte und als das
passiert ist
Liebe Politikerinnen und Politiker
liebes deutsches Volk warum ist es
möglich wir haben uns an euch gewendet
wir haben gesagt diese Nord Streams das
ist eine Art Vorbereitung auf den Krieg
und dann haben wir die Antwort vernommen
es ist rein wirtschaftlich es ist
Wirtschaft Wirtschaft Wirtschaft das war
aber der Mörser für die neue Mauer wir
haben euch gefragt was Ukraine tun soll
um in die NATO zu kommen um die
Garantien für ihre Sicherheit zu
erhalten dann haben wir als als Antwort
vernommen die Entscheidung ist noch
nicht auf dem Tisch und es ist noch
nicht absehbar welche
Plätze welchen Platz wir einzunehmen
haben und wenn Sie uns jetzt fragen
ob die Ukraine in die EU eintreten soll
ja für manche ist das Politik
aber das sind auch Steine das sind
Steine für die neue Mauer wenn das uns
versagt wird als wir nach Sanktionen
gefragt haben präventiven Sanktionen wir
haben Europa angesprochen die Welt
angesprochen und sie angesprochen und
Sanktionen die denn dem Aggressoren
zeigen würden dass sie stark sind wir
haben gesehen dass es auf lange Bank
geschoben wurde dass sie weiterhin
wirtschaftlich tätig sein wollen das ist
um Wirtschaft geht und jetzt sind die
wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen zwischen
ihrem Land und dem Land das einen
grausamen Krieg von Zaun gebrochen hat
das ist eine Brücke die über diese Mauer
geschlagen wird die uns trennt und sie
wollen nicht hinter die Mauer gucken und
sie ist zwischen uns in aber gibt es
weder eine Mauer und deshalb führen noch
nicht alle was wir heute erfahren und
ich spreche sie an im Namen aller
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine ja wir haben
schon über Mario Paul gesprochen ja auch
im Namen der
Anwohner Mario Puls einer wunderschönen
friedlichen Stadt die eingekesselt wird
und einfach dem Erdboden gleichgemacht
wird alles was dort drin gibt wird
vernichtet und alle ebenfalls
hunderttausende Menschen sind in der
Stadt unter Beschuss 24 Stunden am Tag
ohne Essen ohne Trinkwasser ohne Strom
einfach rund um die Uhr ohne Verbindung
und das sind Wochen die russischen
Truppen unterscheiden nicht zwischen
zivilen und militärischen Objekten
zwischen Zivilisten und unsere Armee
alles ist für sie eine Zielscheibe und
ein Theater wo hunderte Menschen zufl
gefunden haben wurde gestern dem
Erdboden gleichgemacht
Geburtskliniken
Kinderkrankenhäuser
Wohnquartiere ohne jegliche militärische
Verbindung es wird alles zerstört rund
um die Uhr und die humanitären Konvois
können die Stadt in die Stadt nicht
eintreten diese eingekesselte Stadt seit
fünf Tagen wird es ununterbrochen
geschossen dort damit wir unsere
Menschen nicht retten können sie können
das alles sehen wenn Sie
über diese Mauer schauen wollen wenn Sie
sich daran erinnern dass
die Berliner Luftbrücke die es damals
gab weil der Luftraum sicher war damals
in den 40er es wurden keine Bomben vom
Himmel abgeworfen aber hier jetzt bei
uns in unserem Land können wir keine
Luftbrücke aufbauen vom Himmel kommen
nur russische Bomben und russische
Raketen ich spreche sie an im Namen der
älteren Ukraine die den Zweiten
Weltkrieg erfahren haben die sich die
überlebt haben unter Besatzung 80 vor 80
Jahren die auch Barben Jahr überlebt
haben
letztes Jahr war
Bundespräsident Stein mal in Babel ja
ich bin sehr dankbar dafür um diese
Tragödie zu bedenken und diese Ort wurde
von russischen Raketen auch getroffen
genau dieser Ort und eine Familie wurde
getötet die dort war um der Opfer zu
gedenken babinar
in 80 Jahren nach 80 Jahren passiert so
etwas und ich spreche sie an und
täglich oder jedes Jahr wiederholen die
Politiker nie wieder und jetzt sehen wir
dass diese Worte einfach nichts wert
sind in Europa wird ein Volk vernichtet
es wird versucht alles zu vernichten was
wir was uns teuer ist
wofür wir leben und ich spreche sie an
im Namen unserer Armee unserer Soldaten
die unser Land verteidigen und die Werte
verteidigen von denen so oft gesprochen
wird
in Europa in Europa überall
Freiheit Gleichheit Möglichkeit frei zu
leben und nicht
sich einem anderen Land zu unterwerfen
die Ansprüche hat auf unser Gebiet wir
versuchen es zu verteidigen ohne ihre
tatkräftige Unterstützung warum sind die
sie ist ein Land das über dem Ozean
liegt etwas näher an uns jetzt warum was
Hilfe angeht weil als eine Mauer ist
eine Mauer die wir anscheinend noch
nicht sehen aber wir versuchen
wir kämpfen dafür um unseren Volk zu
bewahren zu schützen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
liebes deutsches Volk ich bin sehr
dankbar an alle die uns unterstützen an
einfacher deutsche die den Ukrainern
helfen an die Journalisten die ehrlich
und aufrichtig ihre Sache tun und das
ganze böse zeigen was Russland über uns
gebracht hat an die deutschen Firmen die
Moral über dem Profit gestellt haben und
schon diesen Schritt getan haben die
nicht nur Wirtschaft Wirtschaft
Wirtschaft sehen und wir sind auch den
Politikerinnen Politiker dankbar die
doch diese Mauer versuchen zu
durchbrechen die
schritteunternehmen die zwischen dem
russischen Geld und den Toten
ukrainischen Kindern leben wählen sich
für das Leben aussprechen und für
Sanktionen gegen Russland die uns
Frieden bringen können aussprechen wir
sind Ukraine wir sind in Europa und ich
bin denen dankbar die auch dafür sich
ausgesprochen haben Russland vom Swift
abzuschalten sich für embargo
aussprechen das was diesen Krieg
finanziert und für diejenigen die dafür
einstehen das Ukraine ein Mitglied der
EU hört sie sind schon viele und es
werden mehr ich bin denen dankbar die
übermauern schauen können und die wissen
dass die Verantwortung über allem steht
weil es um Menschen geht wir werden es
ist schwierig für uns ohne ihre Hilfe
ohne die Hilfe der Welt das zu
überstehen und die Ukraine zu
verteidigen Europa zu verteidigen ohne
das was sie noch für uns tun können
damit man sich nicht hinterher fragt
nach diesem Krieg nach den zerstörten
Städten
die Städte werden nach 80 Jahren wieder
gebombt ausgebombt Don Bass damit man
sich nach 80 Jahren
nach so vielen getöteten Menschen
gefallenen Menschen nach 80 Jahren nicht
fragt was ist denn diese historische
Verantwortung die es immer noch gibt vor
der Ukraine vor 80 Jahren und damit man
jetzt
keine neue Mauer aufbaut und das nicht
etwas passiert wofür man
wofür man wieder diese lange
Aufarbeitung braucht das verspreche ich
sie an und sage wir brauchen Hilfe auch
für Europa Europa kann ich überleben und
ihre Werte bewahren ein ehemaliger
Schauspieler ein Präsident von
Vereinigten Staaten Ronald Reagan hat
mal gesagt in Berlin
er hat gesagt Mr Gorbatschow Terror
zerstören sie diese Mauer und das sage
ich ich an sie lieber Herr Bundeskanzler
Scholz zerstören sie diese Mauer die
geben Sie Deutschland die Führungsrolle
die sie die Deutschland verdient und
damit ihre Nachfahren stolz sind auf sie
unterstützen sie den Frieden
unterstützen sie die Ukraine stoppen Sie
diesen Krieg helfen Sie uns diesen Krieg
zu stoppen es lebe die Ukraine
[Applaus]
ja Standing Ovations langer Applaus für
den ukrainischen Präsidenten für seine
Rede zum Deutschen Bundestag
es sind viele Punkte dabei gewesen wir
haben es vorher schon quasi erwartet
Kritik viel Emotionen wir wollen das
ganze einordnen zunächst einmal mit
Chuck unterlab energy die die Rede eben
in Berlin verfolgt hat unsere Hauptstadt
Korrespondentin jakutala wie ist diese
Rede zu sehen da ist viel Kritik drin
gewesen wenn er sagt es gibt da eine
Mauer das heißt die Ukraine ist getrennt
vom Westen da ist die Freiheit da ist
die Ukraine die angegriffen wird und er
hat gesagt ich bin all denjenigen
dankbar die helfen die Sanktionen
aussprechen die ein Embargo aussprechen
die für eine Ausnahme der Russen von 15
das sind ja alles Sachen wo Deutschland
eben auf Bremse gestreten getreten hat
und insofern ist das eine deutliche
Kritik gewesen ja das war sie eindeutig
er hat ja zu Beginn seiner Rede relativ
weit vorne schon gesagt das was getan
wurde kam teilweise zu spät und man sehe
jetzt dass die Sanktionen nicht so
wirken wie erhofft er hat natürlich auch
mit anerkannt dass Deutschland an der
ein oder anderen Stelle hilft hat sich
auch persönlich an die Bevölkerung
gewandt hat auch einzelnen gedankt die
sich privat einsetzen hat den Firmen
gedankt die wie er es gesagt hat Profit
übergewinnen stellen aber es war doch
auch die ganze Bitterkeit sehr deutlich
die er empfindet an Gesichts der
ausbleibenden Unterstützung bei den
Forderungen die er hat der NATO-Beitritt
ist ein ein Thema gewesen dass er
genannt hat der der EU-Beitritt den die
wenn ihr jetzt anstrebt wo die
Bundesregierung nicht zu denen gehört
die sagen das sollten wir unter
vereinfachten Bedingungen sehr schnell
machen sondern eher zurückhaltend ist
und auf der Seite derer steht die sagen
dafür gibt es Prozesse und diesen
Prozess könnten wir jetzt gehen also
genau nicht das Zeichen setzt was sich
die Ukraine wünscht da war viel Kritik
drin tatsächlich und auch wieder das was
er auch schon in den USA gemacht hat er
hat versucht die deutschen emotional zu
erreichen und eine ein Bild zu schaffen
ein rhetorisches Bild das wir hier
verstehen können dieses Motiv der Mauer
hat er sehr sehr häufig gebracht und hat
gesagt was hier gerade passiert dass ihr
uns nicht so helft wie wir uns das
wünschen das ist eine neue Mauer in
Europa die Ukraine sieht sich ja ganz
klar als Teil Europas silensky hat immer
versucht sich Europa weiter anzunähern
und sagt jetzt eben ihr habt das nicht
zugelassen mit eurem ganzen zögern mit
eurer Gewinnorientierung bei Geschäften
mit Russland habt ihr die Mauer
aufgebaut und er hat jetzt die USA nicht
direkt angesprochen aber sagte das der
Partner die die weit weg auf der anderen
Seite des Atlantiks sitzen näher dran
sind als uns an an uns als Ihr also die
USA näher dran sind als die Staaten in
der Nachbarschaft
das sei nicht gut also das sei schon
bemerkenswert und was er auch gemacht
hat das muss man auch ganz deutlich
sagen er hat die Verantwortung
Deutschlands für die Ukraine noch mal
zurückgezogen auf den Zweiten Weltkrieg
in dem die Ukraine schrecklich gelitten
haben und unter den Angriffen der Nazis
und hat im Namen der Überlebenden des
Massakers von barbinar direkt noch mal
appelliert dass wir helfen sollten dass
Deutschland helfen sollte das ist eine
besondere Verantwortung hat und klar
gemacht dass er die Übernahme dieser
Verantwortung hier sehr vermisst
und genauso wie du das sagst deshalb
auch dass er deutlich der deutliche
Hinweis zu Ronald Reagan der gesagt hat
Mr gabberschaft tare this walldown also
reißen sie diese Mauer ein da hat ein
amerikanischer Präsident und er sagte
absichtlich eben einen Schauspieler
ehemaliger Schauspieler für Deutschland
etwas getan dass eine Mauer eingerissen
wird und insofern ist in dem
Zusammenhang der Appell zu verstehen an
den Kanzler von Deutschland Scholz nun
auch in dieser Richtung zu wirken wir
reden gleich weiter Chuck unterler
wollen aber mit ins Boot holen Brigitta
Triebel von der
Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung sie leitet
eigentlich muss man sagen das Büro der
Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung in rakif ist
aber jetzt aus verständlichen Gründen in
Deutschland Frau Triebel schön dass Sie
mit dabei sind und die Frage erstmal an
sie das müssen wir unbedingt wissen was
hören sie denn von ihren Kollegen wie
ist die Lage erstmal in haakev um den
ganzen Hintergrund auch zu erfahren
ja guten Tag die Lage in hakik ist
dramatisch sie ist noch nicht so
dramatisch wie in mariopol weil die
Stadt noch nicht eingekesselt ist aber
wir sehen in Haki die russische
Strategie die im Moment auf allen
Städten in allen Städten angewandt wird
in der Ukraine vor allem in der
Ostukraine also die Städte werden
dauerhaft bombardiert auch heute habe
ich wieder sehr viele Meldungen auf mein
Handy bekommen dass man sich in Keller
in Luftschutzräume begeben soll weil es
abermals Angriffe gibt nachts und
tagsüber ich höre auch dass sehr sehr
viele Menschen mittlerweile die Stadt
verlassen haben weil es einfach kaum
noch auszuhalten ist und die die vor Ort
sind versuchen entweder zu überleben
oder haben sich den Widerstand
angeschlossen und bereiten die Stadt vor
falls es noch einmal ein Versuch geht
von russischer Seite diese Stadt
einzunehmen
jetzt haben wir die Rede vom
ukrainischen Präsidenten verfolgt er hat
das was sie ja sagen auch angesprochen
Marie upol eine friedliche Stadt sagt
der alles wird dort vernichtet 24
Stunden Dauerbeschuss und ja sehr
emotional hatte ja auch noch mal dran
erinnert wie das Schicksal der Menschen
ist dieser drei Wochen dann eben ohne
Wasser ohne Strom etc da sind dass
Theater was gestern bombardiert worden
ist wo Menschen Zuflucht gesucht haben
wie sehen Sie die Rede die sie jetzt ja
auch mitverfolgt haben wie bewerten Sie
die wie ordnen Sie die Worte von
selensky ein
ich denke es war eine starke Rede er hat
vieles erwähnt was auch ich erwartet
habe also dieser emotionale Appell und
natürlich auch die Kritik an Deutschland
und ich denke er hat da einen sehr
bunten Punkt getroffen in den
deutsch-ukrainischen Beziehungen in den
letzten acht Jahren denn er hat ganz
klar gefragt warum hat Deutschland denn
unsere Bedenken unsere Warnung nicht
gesehen übrigens auch die Warnung Polens
und aus dem Baltikum und wo ist denn die
historische Verantwortung Deutschlands
gegenüber der Ukraine auch ein ein ganz
schwieriger Punkt in den Beziehungen
denn deutsche Politiker haben im Januar
noch der Ukraine gesagt wir liefern
keine Waffen aus historischen Gründen
aber auch hier hat der Präsident
versucht zu sagen ja aber was ist denn
jetzt konkret in diesen Kriegsfall in
dieser existenziellen Bedrohung für die
Ukraine dann wirklich die historische
Verantwortung und er hat es eben auch in
die Gegenwart gezogen er hat gesagt was
ist denn jetzt die Unterstützung warum
zögert Deutschland jetzt abermals wenn
es um weitere Wirtschaftssanktionen geht
wenn es darum geht die Ukraine auf ihren
europäischen Weg noch stärker zu
unterstützen also ich denke er war sehr
direkt er war sehr emotional und hat
denke ich auch die Politiker und
Politikerinnen im Bundestag zum
Nachdenken gebracht das ist eine
Strategie die wir bei Ihnen seit
Kriegsbeginn sehen und auch schon in den
Wochen davor er versucht einfach mit
diesem Appell den moralischen Druck auf
die
Regierungen im Westen zu erhöhen um dann
tatsächlich noch weitere Unterstützung
zu bekommen und das haben wir ja gestern
in den USA gesehen dass ist erfolgreich
nun hat selenski ja auch schon
gesprochen zum EU-Parlament zum
amerikanischen Kongress per
videoschaltet zum britischen Unterhaus
jetzt man könnte sagen erst relativ spät
zum Deutschen Bundestag ist das auch so
ein bisschen vielleicht symbolisch
ja das kann man durchaus so sehen also
generell waren
die bidensgehe und seiner Regierung und
den deutschen Regierungen in den letzten
zwei Jahren nicht besonders gut ja also
er hatte schon spätestens seit Sommer
2021 immer wieder sehr deutlich seine
Enttäuschung geäußert das ist keine
Waffenlieferung gibt dass eben
Deutschland bei dem EU NATO-Beitritt
zurückhaltend ist also es gab da nie
würde ich sagen sehr gute Beziehungen
und vor allem eben kein Verständnis
zwischen den Regierenden über die Lage
des anderen und das hat man auch schon
in den Wochen vor dem Krieg gesehen dass
er bezüglich Deutschland immer sehr
zurückhaltend ist
jetzt würde ich sie gerne einfach mal
fragen ist das vielleicht auch der
geschickte Redner der Schauspieler der
Pfiffikus silensky ich sage das
absichtlich so der ganz geschickt hier
Olaf Scholz packt den ich greife das auf
was sie sagen da zögert Deutschland da
zögert einen Kanzler Tritt auf die
Bremse geht nicht entschieden voran und
er hat ja eigentlich mit den Worten so
ein bisschen versucht kannst ja Scholz
bei der Ehre zu packen er möge doch
bitte der Kanzler sein auf dem man stolz
sein kann
ja natürlich also man merkt selenski
einfach an dass er der Rhetoriker ist
dass er ganz genau weiß welche Punkte er
sozusagen bespielen muss und zu sagen
also auch den Kanzler direkt
anzusprechen und zu sagen übernehmen sie
endlich die Führungsrolle und eben nicht
sagen wir mal für ein wirtschaftliches
Projekt sondern für die Verteidigung der
europäischen Werte für die Verteidigung
der europäischen Sicherheit da kann man
natürlich als deutscher Bundeskanzler
der eben auch immer wieder auf die
Geschichte referiert Deutschlands und
Europa
da kann man natürlich nur zuhören und
ich bin gespannt ob es da noch mal eine
Reaktion gibt
was ich noch hinzufügen möchte ich denke
selensky hat auch in dieser Rede noch
mal klar gemacht er möchte jetzt weitere
Unterstützung ja ob es nun weitere
Wirtschaftssanktionen sind oder weitere
militärlieferungen für die Ukraine ist
der Faktor Zeit im Moment entscheidend
jeder Tag in dem das ukrainische Militär
und die Gesellschaft und dieser Staat
durchhält ist schon ein kleiner Erfolg
und deswegen ist die Strategie selenskys
eben jetzt jeden Tag noch weitere
Unterstützung durch solche Reden unter
anderem zu bekommen denn mit mit dieser
auch militärischen Unterstützung
verspricht man sich eben diesen Krieg
zumindest noch so lange fortsetzen zu
können bis die russische Seite
vielleicht zu ernsthaften Verhandlung
bereit ist
dann wollen wir wir reden sofort weiter
aber auch noch mal sharko runterladen
energy ins Boot holen und sie eben
fragen das was sie gerade sagen Frau
Triebel kann denn Deutschland sozusagen
mehr Unterstützung liefern was Vertriebe
gerade sagt was helensky fordert um eben
länger durchzuhalten die Punkte diese
Lenski angesprochen hat EU-Beitritt die
Punkte die indirekt angesprochen sind
Flugverbotszone etc was er ja auch die
in Amerikanern gesagt hat das ist ja
alles bisher negativ beschieden worden
wie realistisch ist das dass durch diese
Rede sich was ändert und diese das Mehr
an Unterstützung an die Ukraine wirklich
kommen wird also das realistischste ist
glaube ich dass die ukrainische
Regierung weiter von der deutschen
Bundesregierung enttäuscht sein wird
denn sie wird die Bundesregierung wird
selensky nicht in allen Punkten
Entgegenkommen also beim NATO-Beitritt
ist vollkommen klar der ist
ausgeschlossen das hat selensky auch
zuletzt in mehreren reden angedeutet
dass das
mittlerweile auch begreift obwohl die
Ukraine ja den NATO Beitritt in ihre
Verfassung soger reingeschrieben hat als
Ziel aber davon verabschiedet er sich
gerade beim EU-Beitritt ist Deutschland
zögerlich möchte keinen beschleunigten
Beitritt aber sagt natürlich
selbstverständlich reden wir euch mit
euch darüber und halten die Türen offen
konkreter wird es dann bei dem was schon
läuft nämlich bei Sanktionen da hat
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
gestern noch einmal gesagt es werden
weitere Schritte vorbereitet er wollte
das nicht weiter ausführen mit Verweis
darauf dass man der russischen Seite
keine Hinweise darauf geben möchte aber
da werden werden weitere Sanktionen
kommen was das nun bedeutet ob das zum
Beispiel das geforderte komplette
embargo von Gas Öl und kohle-lieferungen
aus Russland zum Beispiel
sein kann das ist unklar klar ist dass
die Bundesregierung da zum Beispiel auch
sehr auf der Bremse steht immer wieder
sagt das kann man nur machen wenn man es
auch lange durchhält und Deutschland
kann das nicht lange durchhalten weil
wir zu abhängig sind da wird jetzt
durchgerechnet was möglich wäre wenn man
hier hinter den Kulissen in Berlin mit
Leuten redet will es aber auch keiner
wirklich komplett ausschließen also alle
sagen man muss sehen wie sich die Lage
entwickelt wenn es alles noch viel
schrecklicher wird ist auch das nicht
ausgeschlossen
ja es wird hier bei uns kräftig
diskutiert das Thema NATO was du
angeschnitten hast oder was wir
besprochen haben
Alexander der Große schreibt über
Youtube bei aller nuklearer Bedrohungen
durch Putin der Westen muss eine rote
Linie ziehen schreibt er die nicht nur
identisch ist mit der nato-außengrenze
das ist ja bisher die Haltung
solltenberg sagt die Ukraine ist nicht
in der NATO wenn ein Angriff auf Polen
wäre dann wäre das der Verteidigungsfall
das sieht eher hier anders und sagt und
ein anderer User Chris Breuer schreibt
über Youtube die NATO einsetzen die
Ukraine ist ein begründeter
Verteidigungsfall anderer sehen ist
anders es gibt mehrere Gegenstimme Beate
juice 88 schreibt kein NATO-Einsatz denn
wenn die NATO sich richtig einmischt
dann beginnt der dritte Weltkrieg also
bitte die NATO außen lassen und Diana
Zwahlen stimmt über Youtube zu die NATO
darf nicht eingreifen dann haben wir den
Dritten Weltkrieg also das wird kräftig
diskutiert und eine andere bestimmten
Stimme die möchte ich an Dich
weiterleiten schaut runterladen da
schreibt Viola keft über Youtube
Russland ist durch putinskrieg
wirtschaftlich und politisch isoliert es
ist nur noch eine Frage der Zeit
gleichzeitig hat aber silensky deutlich
gemacht dass es wohl immer noch viele
viele Kontakte von Konzernen Konzernen
zu Russland gibt obwohl Russland eben
doch den Westen bedroht ist es wirklich
so dass es nur noch eine Frage der Zeit
ist oder hat selenski nicht deutlich
gemacht die Sanktionen reichen bisher
nicht aus
ich kann zum
genau das auch hofft und eben davon
ausgeht dass der wirtschaftliche Druck
so groß ist das Putin hoffentlich bald
aufgeben muss dass es die Haltung die
die Bundesregierung zusammen mit den mit
der Europäischen Union und den USA
vertritt inwiefern das stimmt werden nur
die nächsten Wochen zeigen also die
Sanktionen sind tatsächlich so
weitreichend wie man sie bisher noch
nicht gesehen hat dass man es gab noch
nie Sanktionen gegen eine Notenbank in
dieser Art und Weise wir hören hier von
Politikerinnen und von Experten dass das
Geld was noch nach Russland fließt auch
durch Geschäfte Putin nicht mehr zugute
kommt weil die Mechanismen fehlen mit
denen er an dieses Geld rankommen könnte
und es einsetzen könnte aber wie gesagt
das muss man alles unter den Vorbehalt
stellen dass es diese Sanktionen so noch
nie gegeben hat und dass wir noch nicht
wissen ob sie dann tatsächlich so wirken
dann gibt es im Hintergrund auch immer
noch die Frage wie wird sich zum
Beispiel China verhalten dass ich nicht
an Sanktionen beteiligt oder auch Indien
dass ich auch nicht an Sanktionen
beteiligt kann Russland von dieser Seite
Unterstützung und auch noch auch noch
wirtschaftliche Beziehungen erwarten das
könnte dann alle sanktionsbemühungen
wieder untergraben und dann dauert es
eben länger bis sie greifen könnten
damit gibst du sozusagen eine Antwort
auf ein Kommentar hier Thomas Rabenstein
schreibt die Ukraine hat die Solidarität
und Unterstützung der Weltgemeinschaft
Putin hat diesen Angriffskrieg bereits
moralisch verloren und hat nur noch
Freunde wie Nordkorea China und Syrien
da also ein bisschen Widerspruch von dir
denn China ist durchaus ein starker
Partner und kann da doch für sehr viel
Unterstützung sorgen jakundala vielen
vielen Dank erst einmal für die
Einschätzung und wir haben eben schon
über die Hauptpersonen heute nämlich den
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski
gesprochen was ist er für ein Typ
erschafft es eine emotionale Rede zu
halten deutliche Kritik gleichzeitig zu
verpacken mit einem Appell an Hilfe auch
an Ehre und er ist da sehr gewieft
sozusagen ein bisschen blitzte auch
heute der Mann durch der er ist nämlich
eigentlich einen Schauspieler der im
tatsächlichen Leben zum Präsidentenamt
genauso gekommen ist wie in einem
Bekannten Film in dem er eine solche
Rolle gespielt hat
das die Serie Diener des Volkes silensky
wird zum Star nicht nur in der Ukraine
sondern auch in Russland er spielt einen
Geschichtslehrer der zum Präsidenten
gewählt wird es wird die Rolle seines
Lebens
das ungläubige Staunen über den Prunk in
der Dienstvilla silensky nimmt man das
ab
und die Fiktion wird zur Realität
selensky tritt mit der Partei die so
heißt wie seine Serie zur
Präsidentschaftswahl 2019 an
silensky stammt aus einer jüdischen
Familie aus der Südukraine zu Hause
wurde russisch gesprochen er ist Jurist
hat aber schon früh auf Comedy gesetzt
die Wahlnacht bringt die Sensation so
hoch wie niemand vor ihm gewinnt
selensky es ist diese Nacht in der er
zum Politiker wird alles ist möglich
ruft er seinen Landsleuten aber auch den
Nachbarländern zu
die Ukraine hatten die Schnauze voll von
all den festgefahrenen Reformen der
blockierten wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung
sie wollten das System einfach neu
starten
den Krieg hat selensky geerbt er wird
zum beherrschenden Thema seiner
Präsidentschaft damals schon 13.000 Tote
im Donbass silenski versucht
entschlossen Russland zum Einlenken zu
bringen
Kriegsgefangene werden ausgetauscht der
Präsident begrüßt Sie persönlich am
Flughafen
aber ein Draht zu Putin findet er nicht
einmal im dezember 2019 in Paris treffen
die beiden aufeinander
konkrete Ergebnisse gibt es nicht
innenpolitisch versucht silensky sich
als korruptionsbekämpfer sein Name
allerdings findet sich auch in den
Pandora papers offshore-konten passen
nicht zum Image eines Saubermanns seine
Zustimmungswerte sinken
als russische Truppen an den Grenzen der
Ukraine stehen fordert selensky
Unterstützung des Westens und macht das
was er am besten kann Kommunikation per
Social Media auch dann noch als Putin
die Ukraine wirklich angreift
ja tut ich bin hier wir werden unsere
Waffen nicht niederlegen wir werden
unser Land verteidigen weil unsere Waffe
die Wahrheit ist und die Wahrheit ist
das ist unser Land unser Staat unsere
Kinder und wir werden all das
Verteidigen
silensky als Superman mit seinen Kindern
und seiner Frau die im Land geblieben
sind sie hat die Bilder auf ihrem
instagram-account geteilt der Plattform
bei der es vor allem ums Image geht im
21 Jahrhundert wird der Krieg auch auf
Social Media geführt
selensky ist jetzt ein kriegspräsident
verleiht Orden tröstet verwundete es ist
eine Rolle von der er gehofft hatte sie
nie spielen zu müssen
[Musik]
dann fragen wir Brigitta Triebel sie ja
eigentlich Leiterin des Konrad Adenauer
stiftungsbüro in hakif ist wie sehen
denn die Ukraine diesen Präsidenten
selensky was hören sie denn von Kollegen
wenn sie ja nun täglich die
Videobotschaften die Appelle die Aufrufe
von ihm hören
ja es ist tatsächlich so wie auch der
Bericht gesagt hat alle Ukrainer oder
fast alle Ukrainer stehen hinter diesen
Präsidenten sie sehen sich jetzt vereint
in diesem Krieg gegen Russland
und sie sehen sich auch gut geführt von
diesen Präsidenten also es gab Umfragen
vor etwa eine Woche mehr als weit mehr
als 90 Prozent der Ukraine und
Ukrainerin unterstützen seine Politik
also auch den Widerstand und das was ich
mitbekomme die Menschen schauen wirklich
seine Nachrichten seine Videos sie
folgen ihm und Sie fühlen sich wirklich
von ihm geführt und ich habe eine
Ukrainerin hat zu mir letztens gesagt es
ist der erste Präsident der wirklich
etwas für uns tut der wirklich für uns
da ist und das Interessante daran ist
vor dem Krieg war er ja schon lange gar
nicht schon lange nicht mehr so beliebt
also das hat sich grundsätzlich
verändert
aber das wenn ich das noch hinzufügen
darf das trifft nicht nur auf den
Präsidenten zu wir sind in Deutschland
sehr fokussiert auf diese Person es ist
auch nach drei Wochen Krieg erstaunlich
wie gut weiterhin der gesamte
ukrainische Staatsapparat funktioniert
also die Ministerien funktionieren die
Minister auch sie melden sich täglich zu
Wort und versuchen den Menschen
Informationen zu vermitteln den Stand
aus ukrainischer Sicht mitzugeben aber
auch die lokalen Behörden ich verfolge
das gerade in Haki die Stadtverwaltung
und auch die Regionalverwaltung sie
arbeiten weiter und kommunizieren
wirklich stündlich mit den Menschen und
das gibt den Menschen eben genau das
Gefühl was der Präsident auch vermitteln
will die Ukraine lebt die Ukraine gibt
es noch
ich meine sie haben völlig recht wollen
wir nicht vergessen da gibt es auch die
Klitschko Brüder vitale Klitschko der
Bürgermeister in Kiew sein Bruder zu ihm
geeilt und beide vereint richten die
Appelle einerseits an die Bürger an die
Landsleute aber eben auch an den Westen
wenn wir denken an Videobotschaften des
Bürgermeisters von Marie upol der aber
nun festgenommen worden ist nicht mehr
da ist der stellvertretende
Bürgermeister sendet heute
Videobotschaften sie haben völlig Recht
da funktioniert doch eine ganze Menge
und das ist doch ein gewaltiger
Unterschied zu Russland ich will jetzt
nicht die Metapher der Mauer aufbauen
aber es ist doch ein ein riesiger
Unterschied ein riesiger Graben da
silensky die ukrainische Führung und
dort Putin wie er sich verhält
ja definitiv also ich denke das ist auch
bewusst von der ukrainischen Politik so
inszeniert wie ihre Korrespondentin
schon gesagt hat selenski inszeniert
sich als antiputin aber auch dieser
ganze Staat Ukraine Tod das und da kommt
natürlich den Ukrainern zugute dass sie
Russland sehr sehr gut kennen auch
selensky war ja immer wieder mit als
Schauspieler in Russland seine Serien
waren alle immer russischsprachig das
zielte immer auf den russischen Markt
und man weiß ganz genau sozusagen nicht
nur wie man die russische Bevölkerung
erreicht man kennt auch das System Putin
und das System Russlands und darauf
zielt das genau diesen Kontrast
herzustellen
dann zum Schluss weil sie eben die
Ukraine gut kennen eben in haakev das
büroleiten was ist ihre Hoffnung was ist
ihre Einschätzung wie sieht die Zukunft
aus wir haben es ja jetzt gehört
silensky die Ukraine braucht Zeit
das würde der Ukraine helfen auf der
anderen Seite ist in den letzten Tagen
und Wochen auch deutlich geworden dass
eben Putin das System Putin jeden
Inneren protestprotest aus dem Inneren
in Russland niederschlägt also die
Hoffnung dass es da einen Umsturz von
innen gibt und damit der Krieg beendet
wird die ist ja auch nicht sehr groß wie
sehen Sie das wo ist ihre Hoffnung
ja also wir sollten nicht zu viel
Hoffnung auf einen inneren Systemwechsel
in Russland setzen vor allem weil wir
die nicht beeinflussen können also das
ist wirklich nur Hoffnung und und wenig
reale Erwartungen ich denke es gibt
verschiedene Szenarien es kann durchaus
sein dass die russische Seite schon sehr
stark unter Druck ist bei mehr als
10.000 toten Soldaten
könnte es sein dass sie vielleicht doch
zu einem echten Waffenstillstand bereit
sind und zu echten Verhandlungen das ist
jetzt schwer einzuschätzen darauf würde
denke ich die ukrainische Seite eingehen
also hätten wir zumindest ein
Waffenstillstand kein Frieden aber
zumindest einen Stock der Kampfhandlung
das wäre ein Szenario ein zweites
Szenario kann aber auch sein dass die
russische Seite weiter eskaliert dass
sie tatsächlich weiter an ihren Zielen
festhalten Kiew einzunehmen das Land zu
dem militarisieren und wie Sie es nennen
denazifizieren das würde bedeuten dass
die Ukraine weiterhin erbitterten
Widerstand leistet das würde für die
Welt und für Europa bedeuten dass wir
nicht nur mehr zerstörte Städte sehen
sondern noch viel mehr Leid und noch
viel mehr Bilder
von denen wir uns jetzt noch gar keine
Vorstellung machen können
also es ist im Moment noch alles offen
wie es sich weiterentwickelt ich hoffe
natürlich
für ein sehr sehr schnellen
Waffenstillstand und ich hoffe natürlich
dass die russischen Truppen abziehen und
die territoriale Integrität der Ukraine
wieder hergestellt ist aber ich kann mir
immer noch nicht vorstellen wie Russland
tatsächlich
dann einen solchen Waffenstillstand
zustimmt und vor allem welche
Sicherheitsgarantien man der Ukraine
dann geben kann denn nach diesen Krieg
ist jedem Ukrainer klar die Gefahr durch
das Nachbarland ist immer da und ist
immens hoch
dann ist es genauso so wie vor etwas
über drei Wochen noch am Vortag des 24
Februars ist eigentlich unvorstellbar
war dass es so so einem Krieg kommen so
fällt es jetzt schwer zu sehen wie
dieser Krieg gestoppt werden kann frau
Triebel vielen vielen Dank für die
Informationen für Ihre Einschätzung für
die Analyse der Rede von selensky ihnen
alles Gute und vor allen Dingen auch
ihren Kolleginnen und Kollegen in Haake
alles gut vielen Dank
ja und das war unser ZDF heute live zur
Rede des ukrainischen Präsidenten zum
vor dem Deutschen Bundestag zum
Deutschen Bundestag per Videoschalte
eine sehr emotionale Rede eine klare
rede mit durchaus viel Kritik mit klaren
Appellen und dem Versuch die Deutschen
doch irgendwie zu packen die Ukraine
mehr zu unterstützen gleichzeitig aber
auch mit Dank an die Deutschen die das
bereits tun und den Ukrainern helfen
soweit unser Livestream vielen Dank für
das Interesse tschüss und auf
Wiedersehen